there is one very powerful
anti-inflammatory food that is going to
surprise you and I wish I knew about
this a long time ago when I had my
inflammation I had a lot of gut
inflammation but you can apply this to
any inflammation this also applies to
people with autoimmune diseases and
anyone with a condition that is itis
which is inflammation of fill in the
blank now there is a huge connection and
relationship between inflammation in
your joints and inflammation in the gut
many joint inflammatory processes
including many autoimmune diseases
originate in the gut and I'm going to go
through the foods that you should avoid
first okay and then I'm going to tell
you what you should be eating but the
foods that create the most inflammation
would be related to something like
gluten which actually is in grains most
of the grains create inflammation in
your gut most people with arthritis
don't know it but their grains that
they're eating are creating a lot of
inflammation then you have the obvious
things like alcohol sugar junk Foods
another name for Junk Foods would be
ultra processed foods did you realize
that 83% of all the calories in the
grocery store are ultr processed foods
and we wonder why our digestive system
is so messed up now we also have corn
okay corn is very inflammatory it's
usually in some type of processed
refined corn product or high fructose
corn syrup but I think about like
96% of all corn is genetically modified
which means it could have traces of
glyphosate which is considered an
antibiotic it can actually mess with
your gut flora and create other issues
and then then we have soy the same boat
most soy is genetically modified and soy
and corn have lactin which also irritate
your gut which then can stir up the
inflammation and by the way corn is not
a vegetable it's a grain okay and we eat
corn in so many different things corn
chips tortillas it's in a lot of foods
especially at the grocery store and it's
not in a whole form it's in some type of
refined form there's even a new type of
um genetically modified corn that we
have not really done the safety test yet
and that's going to be very interesting
what happens with that one and then of
course we have the the obvious seed oils
too like canola oil the soy oil the corn
oil all the oils that are highly refined
they're Omega 6 they're inflammatory we
also have the A1 milk proteins okay you
always want to get A2 a very safe way to
avoid the A1 is to have like milk
products from either goats or sheep as
in sheep or goat cheese or sheep or goat
Keir both of those products are
fermented and they have additional
benefits and both of them are the A2
type protein but I will say that a lot
of people have casine allergies and that
is the problem but then again they also
might have a lactose milk sugar
intolerance okay and that creates
another issue the same thing with gluten
you don't necessarily have to have an
alergy could just be a gluten
intolerance and then we have just fiber
in general not to mention all the new
functional fibers that they're coming
out with like the cyal corn fiber or the
tapioca fiber all these different fiber
products that are supposedly going to be
good for you but they create more
bloating and inflammation if you have
inflammation wherever it is and if it's
especially in the gut you need to avoid
fiber and that includes all fiber and
especially the so-called healthy like
plant proteins and beans and legumes and
even vegetables that's going to actually
irritate your colon you should probably
do carnivore for a while and you'll
probably feel a lot better but I just
listed all of the foods that greatly
contribute to inflammation so now let's
talk about the most important food to
get rid of your inflammation this food
has a very high level of glutamine in
fact if you look at all the foods out
there with the highest level of
glutamine it would be this food but let
me just explain what glutamine is it's
an amino acid for your colon cells which
is a single layer of cells that line the
inside of your colon this forms the
barrier to your immune system deeper
inside but your intestinal cells are
very hungry for glutamine in fact out of
all the glutamine they hog like 30% of
it okay for themselves
glutamine is very important in producing
ATP energy glutamine fuels the
intestinal layer of the cells as well as
the mucosal layer where all the good
bacteria hang out and glutamine supports
tight junctions you see I originally
talked about this gut being a source of
inflammation but I didn't describe
exactly what's occurring what's
occurring is leaky gut which is
intestinal hyperpermeability you
basically have holes in this single
layer cell that goes right in and larger
molecules of food that are not broken
down can get through there and then your
immune system tags them as a foreign
entity to be destroyed and that's when
you start developing antibodies and
allergies against Foods so this problem
really is a bypass of normal immigration
it doesn't give the normal stamp of
approval through the immune system and
it gets through and it creates a lot of
problems for you so all of those bad
foods I talked about kind of put a hole
through your intestine and glutamine is
the solution for that but now the
question is what food has the most
glutamine and the answer is meat
specifically beef the thing that they're
trying to get rid of right now they're
trying to get rid of cows because of
just some ridiculous reason but beef
gives you a super healing protein
glutamine that can greatly support your
gut and other types of inflammatory
conditions whether you have an
autoimmune or some other type of
non-autoimmune joint problem or whatever
now you can actually take glutamine as
well but beef is the best
anti-inflammatory food that you can
possibly eat in fact before the
ketogenic diet when I was eating all
those carbs and when I switched over to
beef oh my goodness did I feel better it
was incredible I no longer had bloating
and it was really weird because I
thought thought that you needed fiber to
kind of push things through but little
did I know that beef really calmed the
fire down in my gut and a lot of
inflammatory conditions went away I had
arthritis so bad in my hands and my
spine I had no idea it was connected to
my diet and primarily all the carbs and
Grains I was consuming you just have to
try it let's say that you're a vegan and
you want to know what is the best vegan
source of glutamine ready for this okay
cabbage that's right especially red
cabbage but all cabbage is loaded with
glutamine so those are the two foods
that have the most glutamine if you were
to look at like just the spectrum of a
meat and a vegetable and this is also
what I talk about in other videos using
like cabbage for gastritis or an ulcer
or any type of GI inflammatory condition
um you can't really do a lot of other
vegetables and fiber but that's the one
that most people can deal with
especially if you do it in a fermented
form the sauerkraut because that way you
get all this glutamine from the
vegetable but you get the microbes as
well now there are other things that are
loaded with glutamine as well you have
cheese from either a sheep or a goat or
the um kefir like I mentioned you also
have eggs and fish and especially bone
broth okay that's loaded with glutamine
so now I kind of simplified how to heal
your inflammation and gave you the
things that you need to avoid to really
turn this thing around around I'm
telling you if you have inflammation I
don't care what kind you should start
eating these Foods these I would start
basically eating beef and cabbage and
just watch what happens to your
inflammation I think you'll be quite
surprised now because of the censoring
and the suppressing of the algorithms on
YouTube it's becoming more difficult to
find my content and there's a lot of
content that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side now if you have not
seen my video on sauerkraut you should
check it out I put it up right here it's
actually very
interesting